March 2019 is when the UK is leaving the  EU MEP is criticized the lack of  sufficient progress in brexit talks 80%  of companies in Europe have experienced  at least one cybersecurity incident  Parliament wants the EU to invest more  in online safety and the fight against  networks of sex abusers MEP is demanded  that the rights of 400,000 passengers  who were affected by Ryanair's flight  cancellations be enforced they also  asked a better protect workers  conditions in low-cost airlines 2.2 6  million people is said to have voted in  the controversial Catalan independence  referendum Parliament's president  Antonio Tajani called for calm and  profound deliberation in Spain lawmakers  proposed the setup of a new reverse  one-one-two system that would alert  citizens in case of a terrorist attack  or natural catastrophe the telecoms  package also aims to make calls within  the EU cheaper  [Music]  you